in a recent video I discussed a training
program designed to help the average Joe
become a bit more like Batman physically
a bit more Batman if you will
it's a nerdy endeavor no doubt but
Batman is a very cool thought experiment
a look at what the perfect human might
look like in terms of physical and
mental prowess but we all know that
physical strength is only part of the
story when it comes to being Batman
Batman is a super genius he's the
greatest detective on earth he's an
engineer a businessman he can do pretty
much anything
so in this video we're gonna ask a new
question what would these brain training
program look like if you wanted to try
and think more like a Batman
because your brain just like your
muscles can be trained can be developed
and it's something I think that more
people should do many people are happy
to dedicate five hours a week or more to
training their muscles but they don't
give anywhere near the same amount of
time to training their brain and if you
do this you can become smarter more
creative more successful happier so with
that in mind what might a training
program for the brain look like and
using Batman as a model how might Bruce
Wayne approach this question by the end
of this video you'll have an idea of how
brain training works if rain training
works what aspects of your intelligence
you can upgrade and full detail of
program over on the website the link
will be in the description down below
that'll give you a kind of brain split
or the very least a brain day to go
along with your biceps and your legs
though the obvious place to start is
with the one form of brain training that
we absolutely know works this is a
guaranteed win has been backed by loads
of science and of course I'm talking
about meditation on his podcast Tim
Ferriss interviews all kinds of toppity
VORs including athletes business owners
programmers musicians creators etc and
he's found that the one thing that most
of them have in common is that they all
have some kind of meditation practice
but if the word meditation makes you run
for the hills and don't worry
actually meditation is very simple all
it really means is focus so there's lots
of different types of meditation you
have mindfulness you have transcendental
you have Kundalini you have religious
meditation you have kinesthetic
meditation all kinds of different sorts
but they all effective
mean focusing on one thing or another or
trying to empty your mind which is a
kind of focus so you might be focusing
on a candle flame you might be focusing
on a mantra which is just a word you
repeat over and over like um you might
be focusing on a passage from a
religious text you might be focusing on
your own body by being able to focus on
one thing you can choose what you want
to pay attention to what you want to
rise above you can ignore distracting
thoughts and you can focus all of your
cognitive efforts on to solving one
problem or on to reacting to the world
around you let me show that can actually
build new gray matter through meditation
and can increase connectivity throughout
your brain you can increase the weight
of your brain so there's really no
reason not to practice meditation the
best way to start I recommend is with
mindfulness meditation it's a very
simple one you can find simple practices
on youtube or on headspace start with
just three minutes a day because the big
mistake here is to try and bite off more
than you can chew and then not stick
with it so just three minutes
set the timer sit down and just have
three minutes of quiet focusing on your
breathing or your body you all listening
to a guided meditation the next place
you might think to look is with brain
training apps and programs these are
designed to boost your cognitive
abilities so would make sense to check
those out wouldn't it
unfortunately most brain training
programs and apps are not really backed
by science they only seem to be able to
improve your ability to do those tasks
so you'll carry out some kind of game
like a memory game I know you're
actually going to do is get better at
playing that game rather than getting
better in general that's because using
our brain is such a complex thing it's
so dependent on the context is so
multimodal so just watching something on
a screen and picking Birds and hens
isn't quite the same as using a brain
out there in the real world one
systematic review of brain training
programs though found - that did work
they were cognitive fit and brain HQ and
looking at why these seem to have some
kind of benefit they came up with two
explanations one was that they focused
on brain plasticity if you've watched
this channel before then you'll be
familiar with what that is it's
basically the ability of your brain to
grow and change shape in response to
training the best brain training
programs take this into account by
making sure every challenge is always at
the optimum level for your ability so it
gets gradually harder as you improve it
should always be just difficult enough
to provide a challenge but not so
difficult enough that you give up I'll
keep you engaged and interest
and being engaged and interested is what
promotes the production of dopamine and
BDNF among other key neuro chemicals
don't do brain training that's boring
because you might be forcing yourself to
do it but you're not actually gonna be
engaging with it in the same way and
your brain isn't gonna be as plastic cuz
it's not woken up if the brain trains
boring is probably not working the other
thing that could make certain brain
training programs more successful than
others
was focusing on the right aspects of
cognitive ability so one of them is
cognitive processing speed and the other
is working memory working memory is your
ability to hold ideas in your brain for
a short period of time since the ability
to hold a phone number in your head
whilst you look for a pen or your
ability to know where all the players
are on the pitch when you're playing
football without having to look up and
find them if you watch one of my other
videos you'll know that working memory
is closely related to your visualization
skills meaning that boosting working
memory will actually improve your bility
to use your video spatial scratchpad
thereby giving you a far greater
cognitive boost than just helping you to
write down numbers you'll be able to
visualize your next step in a plan
you'll be able to be more aware of your
surroundings you were able to navigate
better the dual n-back test is the
number one way to improve this and it's
been demonstrated by several studies to
work basically it involves looking out
from repetitions in a sequence you can
get loads of apps on Android and iOS and
PC for free to give this a go if you
want it is quite boring though and there
are better ways to train your working
memory for instance playing chess which
requires you to know the positions of
all the players on the board and to
think ahead to know what your next step
is going to be okay don't look away from
the camera close your eyes and then try
and visualize the room you are in in as
much detail as possible as many items
around you as you can the other aspect
of your cognitive performance that can
be improved is cognitive processing
speed this is your ability to make quick
decisions to respond to things quickly
to switch between tasks of course all
this sort of thing is very important if
you're going to be Batman an example of
a small program used on one of these
apps as you're looking at objects as
they appear on a screen and quickly
identifying what they are even though
they're only there in your peripheral
vision of a very short space of time but
again you don't actually need the app in
order to practice this and this is what
I'm really interested in because in
order to improve your brain all you
really need is your
rain the best way to improve your
decision-making skills is to make lots
of decisions and the best way to do that
is to do some kind of job where you're
required to make split-second decisions
every single day under pressure likewise
if you want to be a better negotiator
than should be involved in a job that
makes you negotiate likewise if you want
to be better at problem solving and
creative thinking than being a
programmer is fantastic for that but you
don't even have to leave your house in
order to do this for instance if you
want to improve your ability to quickly
make decisions all you can do is task
yourself with making quick decisions you
don't need to actually be in an
environment where that's critical better
yet try wrapping this forces you to
quickly retrieve memories it trains your
verbal fluency it trains your creativity
puts you in a flow State all these
things likewise if you want to train
your ability to retrieve memories try
visualizing an old room that used to
spend time in where was the last place
you ate out to try and visualize the
scene what did you order what did the
person you were with order for bonus
points try to navigate now to that place
where would you turn what would you pass
on the way whether you're walking we
were driving try and visualize the
entire route from your house to that
destination in order to train your brain
all you need is your brain and there are
several different mental drills you can
use in order to do this and it's
actually again a form of meditation
because you're just focusing on a
particular task and using your brain
choosing to use your brain in that way
in my recent video on body language I
discussed how knowing the theory of body
language isn't enough if you want to
become adept at actually reading it you
need to practice it and the best way to
do this is just to go out and practice
using it sit in a coffee shop or on the
train on your commute to work and just
watch people around you and analyze
their body language this is another form
of a kind of focus exercise a kind of
form of meditation where you're not
actually just meditating another example
I talked about in my ninja training
video where I said that they would sit
and listen very quietly to their
surroundings focusing on small sounds
and they've even have someone dropped a
pin behind them and see if they could
hear it again this is a kind of form of
alternative meditation or a mental
exercise that you can use anywhere so
the objective is basically to meditate
but instead of focusing on emptying your
mind or focusing on just one word you're
focusing on using a specific part of
your brain depending on who you listen
to there are two different theories on
what constitutes intelligence some
people will say it's modal that you have
different types of intelligence you have
gardeners theory on multiple
intelligences so different brain areas
then you have those that say
intelligence is more about whole brain
thinking about the connections between
different brain areas another example of
an alternative form of meditation that I
really like is productive meditation
from the author Cal Newport he wrote
deep work productive meditation simply
means that you're musing on a topic on a
question and trying to come up with
answers so say you're writing a book you
just dedicate a set amount of time to
focusing on that book to thinking about
it what's going to happen it cetera he
recommends doing this on inspiration
walk seeing as walking and especially in
a lush environment is fantastic for
stimulating creativity you could also
use this to run thought experiments
thought experiments are a fantastic way
to think more creatively you ask
yourself if I was given the task of
writing the next Bond film what would I
write you asleep minding your own
business three armed men break into your
house downstairs you have two minutes to
come up with a plan go again you're just
getting outside your comfort zone you're
using your brain in different ways
another form of alternative meditation
is something called image streaming this
one is focused on intentionally building
your ability to visualize which as we've
already seen is closely linked with
working memory which can provide a huge
cognitive boost so image streaming
simply involves letting
images come to your mind and then
describing them out loud as you see them
apparently this is one of the secrets to
why Einstein's brain works so
differently and I've done a whole post
on that I'll link to that one as well
but unfortunately just thinking about
something is not quite the same as
really doing it part of the reason for
this of course is that you have a huge
amount of pressure in the real world you
can think about being Batman all you
like but if you're being attacked by a
group of thugs it's all going to go out
the window this is why when training
Special Forces the military will subject
them to extremely harsh conditions
intended to emulate the kind of
conditions they'd experienced in warfare
so they don't only have to make quick
decisions and build complex weaponry
they have to do it whilst they're being
shouted out by their sergeant and they
have to do it whilst they're in the
blistering cold
I'm very little sleep to get you outside
of your comfort zone and it forces your
brain to really focus in a way that you
can't accomplish when you're sat at home
on the sofa at the same time it teaches
them to adapt better to stressful
situations and of course this is
something that Batman would definitely
need and that all of us could use a
little bit more of when building muscle
you subject your muscles to a kind of
positive stress a kind of you stress and
you need the same thing for your brain
if you really want to see it grow
studies have shown that the top
performing Olympic athletes and the top
performing military personnel are the
ones who can react better to highly
stressful situations these are the ones
that show in extreme stress response
they produce a lot of adrenaline and
other hormones but at the same time it
doesn't make them stressed and confused
it doesn't cause them to shut down
looking inside their brains it seems
that the reason for this is because they
produce extra amounts of neuropeptide Y
and DHEA these are interesting because
DHEA buffers the effects of cortisol in
the hippocampus that means that whilst
you might be very aroused and be
producing a lot of adrenaline you're
still going to have access to your
memories to your reasoning at the same
time neuropeptide Y seems to reduce the
negative effects of adrenaline
meditation can happen to improve both of
these things but likewise so too can
exposure you need to get used to being
in stressful environments so get outside
your comfort zone put yourself up for
that difficult challenge at work go up
and speak to a stranger do something
that makes you feel socially awkward but
what's not quite as good as putting
yourself in that situation as subjecting
yourself to stress is to simulate it
because the military also look at gaming
tournaments when they're recruiting
drone operators that's because a
computer game requires many of the same
things that
to make quick decisions it requires you
to juggle multiple different inputs
multiple different variables and many
studies have shown that computer games
are fantastic for brain training
improving your visual acuity your
decision-making your memory your visual
spatial awareness and this is especially
true of first-person shooters and of
course this makes sense because you're
placed into an environment where you
have to learn new controls then you're
scanning the horizon for bogeys deciding
which target to prioritize quickly
aiming and shooting using your reflexes
what would be even better of course
would be a virtual reality so submerging
yourself even deeper into the virtual
world where you have to use 360 degree
awareness and of course hopefully the
astute of you have realized that sports
would probably do all these things as
well especially ones that require you to
work in a team to be more aware of your
surroundings so computer games and
sports are a fantastic way to build your
brain especially if you're subjecting
yourself to new challenges in those
areas all the time then you might be
wondering why David Beckham isn't a
super genius and the thing is he
probably is in some capacities he
probably has great visual spatial
awareness great body awareness is very
quick to make decisions etc so we need
to practice a spectrum of things if we
want to become the best version of
ourselves mentally so we also need to
keep learning and keep developing those
new skills and that of course is one of
the big things about Batman is he can do
pretty much anything anything that the
writer requires him to do he can do I
think everyone should be constantly
learning something lately I've been
developing my After Effects skills I've
been learning new programming I'm
learning hacking doing this not only
upgrades your repertoire of skills which
is really one of the biggest ways to
open up new possibilities the same time
it also makes your brain more plastic
more focused and more aware as you learn
your brain becomes better at learning it
produces more BDNF and more dopamine as
a result of the fact that you are
learning in terms of what you're going
to learn of course if you want to be
more like Batman then you might learn
hacking and engineering and martial arts
and lock-picking in reality though I
would suggest that you learn something
will benefit you a little bit more
because the big thing about Batman of
course is his discipline in his iron
will Batman has a mad obsession and end
goal that he's working towards and
that's what allows him to dedicate so
much time and effort to Wars that thing
you probably don't hate crime quite as
much as Batman and so you should focus
on something that you want to accomplish
that does make you
passionate you don't really want to
become like Batman without thinking we
want to become the best versions of
ourselves by looking to Batman for
inspiration at the same time work on
projects along the way this will help to
crystallize what you're doing it will
help to contextualize it and it will
give you more motivation because you'll
see yourself progressing those areas
this will give you an excuse to use that
productive thinking big idea thinking
which I talked about in my think like a
Tony Stark video and you never know what
it might lead to of course there are
plenty of nootropics and brain hacks you
can use to enhance your neuroplasticity
and you'll focus on your awareness I'm
not going to go into that right now
because that's another huge topic I've
already done a long video one nootropic
and I'm gonna be coming back to this
soon because I'm finally going to unveil
my flow step but I will say with regards
to new troe fixes don't focus on
stimulants like lots of caffeine on my
Daphne
all that's gonna do is make you wired
instead focus on nutrition that will
help to reinforce brain health at the
same time think about energy metabolic
cognitive enhancers and think about
things that will increase your
plasticity so lion's mane has been shown
to improve BDNF and nerve growth factor
likewise we know that omega-3 fatty acid
can boost myelination we know that it
improves cell membrane permeability
allowing for more communication between
neurons and we know that it's effective
for fighting inflammation potentially
information in the brain as well
I like choline inositol for a whole
bunch of reasons as well as boosting
acetylcholine it can also help me to
increase the number of receptors in your
brain thereby making you more sensitive
to all kinds of neurotransmitters still
tap is an interesting stack that can
potentially boost a long-term
potentiation ie reinforce those neural
connections magnesium 3 and 8 can boost
plasticity especially during sleep
turmeric is popular for plasticity
creatine is excellent for boosting brain
metabolism giving you more energy and
there are plenty of adaptogens and
things like l-theanine they'll help you
to maintain a calm focus when combined
with something like mild caffeine
these things are basically metacognitive
strategies so metacognitive strategies
basically mean thinking about thinking
you're thinking how could I have thought
better next time you do something ask if
you're going about it in the best
possible way ask how focused you are ask
why it is that you're not focusing how
could you train yourself to be better at
the thing that you're not currently
doing to the best of your ability one of
these simplest metacognitive strategies
one of my favorite tricks is simply to
try and do whatever you're doing to the
best of your ability because if you try
harder at the thing you're doing if
you're trying to it faster and better
than you normally do you'll make it more
challenging more difficult remember
that's when you engage that's when you
enter the flow state that's when your
brain becomes more plastic
anything can be brain training if you
approach it in that way that's one of
the main take homes from all this and
the other is that the only thing you
need to train your brain is your brain
and finally do train your brain train it
like a muscle make her brain day make a
braised split check out the link in the
description down below where I've
written one that you could follow for
there's plenty more ideas and I hope
that all this theory in this video have
given you some inspiration some ideas of
your own if not then I hope it's been a
little bit entertaining hope you found
something here interesting if you did
then please leave a like please share it
around that helped me out immensely let
me know in the comments down below what
brain training method you use if you
have any more tips or brain hacks what
else you'd like to see me cover around
this subject I've got lots more on the
way the Nightwind training as you know
the YouTube business video a sleep hack
how to jump higher how to balance
Shaolin training if that all sounds
awesome
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now okay so
now I want to count backwards from 200
in threes and at the same time you're
gonna hum the tune - mary had a little
lamb